monter à cheval c'est un sport mais
depuis les années 60 c'est aussi en soit
ça s'appelle l'équithérapie ses
cavaliers sont presque tous de grands
handicapés physiques
cependant ils pratiquent l'équitation
régulièrement pour eux c'est un moyen de
se replonger dans une vie normale en un
mot dette comme les en france c'est la
psychomotricienne rené de lubersac qu'il
a développée en 1970 elle fonde
l'association handi cheval avec le
kinésithérapeute
hubert labrie il utilise le cheval dans
la rééducation physique ainsi que
psychologique des handicapés le temps
d'une séance le cheval parvient à gommer
le handicap
c'est ce que souligne et hubert labrie
en 1972 pour la première fois ils ne
sont plus handicapé au lieu d'avoir
toujours besoin de lever la tête pour
ceux qui sont en chariot pour la
première fois ils voient les autres duos
et c'est très important pour eux
l'équithérapie s'adapte à tous les
handicaps par exemple à la cécité en
1968 ces cavaliers aveugle chevauchée
uniquement grâce aux indications oral de
leur moniteur il en faut beaucoup de
courage pour moi j'essaie de me tenir
sur un cheval en fermant les yeux je
suis incapable de tenir le
de maintenir avec le liban l' équilibre
justement c'est une des grandes
conquêtes de l'équithérapie et les
résultats peuvent être stupéfiants en
1972 cette maman confirmer les progrès
spectaculaires de sa fille
quadriplégique sa maladie lui donnait le
déséquilibre wayana sur des mouvements
et toujours peur des obstacles lors du
vie de toute chose alors qu'avec le
cheval toutes ces choses là sont
estompées assez rapidement tout autant
que l'exercice le soin et la toilette du
cheval participe également au processus
de guérison du handicap et pour moi
personnellement ça m'a fait beaucoup de
bien à beaucoup de plaisir beaucoup deux
et puis ça m'a appris à avoir des
responsabilités à savoir s'occuper d'un
cheval le soigner le penser et puis en
plus pour moi c'est un ami donc c'est
très important à quoi l'équithérapie
légale mais non conventionnés a explosé
ces dernières années
trois organismes privés proposent des
formations des qui siens et en 2015
trente mille personnes avaient suivi une
équité rapide en près de 400 centres
équestres en france
[Musique]